la feuille de route de mikaël kingsbury
en 2019 et prodigieux en neuf départs
sur le circuit de la coupe du monde de
bosses kingsbury a remporté six
victoires
ses exploits lui ont valu son huitième
gros globe de cristal à titre de
meilleur skieur de tout le circuit
un choix logique pour le titre d'athlète
masculin de l'année au pays
la domination de kingsbury est sans
précédent
il a participé à 114 épreuve de la coupe
du monde des championnats du monde et
des jeux olympiques dans sa carrière
dans ma gagné 63 plus de la moitié est
le champion en vigueur qui expiraient
mais au-delà des chiffres c'est un
moment de rédemption au championnat du
monde qui aura marqué l'année 2010 9,2
kingsbury deux ans auparavant
le québécois n'avait pas gagné l'épreuve
individuelle ni l'épreuve des bosses en
parallèle en février dernier
kingsbury a remporté les deux médailles
d'or j'ai envie de revivre des moments
d'amour puis elle sait qu'il y en aurait
été là mon départ oui c'est tout gagné
et les lieux de la ville et rêver
kingsbury a récolté 21 % des votes au
scrutin de la presse canadienne il est
le premier québécois à gagner ce prix
deux années de suite depuis maurice
richard dans les années 50
ici olivier tremblay radio canada
montréal
[Applaudissements]